[inaudible]
we told you in a previous video how
Saudi Arabia wants to leave behind once
and for all it's addiction to oil and
it's become a nation similar to Dubai or
Abu Dhabi.
In this video we are going to look at
the country in more depth in order to
get an idea of just how this mission to
get free from oil is going
[inaudible].
The thing is there is a specific name,
a leader behind this ambitious plan and
my question to you is,
do you know who this person is?
Well,
for those of you don't,
the person who is turning everything
upside down in Saudi Arabia is Mohammed
bin Salman.
Awesome.
My name alone,
it doesn't explain much.
So now you might be wondering who is
this man really awesome his intentions
and what exactly is he trying to do?
While these are the questions that we're
going to be answering in today's visual
politic video,
so let's get started.
Shall We?
The Prince of change.
He might only be a list of more than 30
years olds,
but Mohammed bin Salman is already one
of the most powerful people in the wells
and he controls more money than we could
ever possibly count formerly while he is
the minister of Defense,
deputy crown prince,
second deputy prime minister,
chief of the royal quarter and chair of
the Council for Economic and Development
Affairs.
So what does all of this mean?
Well,
Mitt kinds of things that the hammer has
been sell mom is in control of well
everything.
He's got complete control over the
country's oil,
over the massive financial reserves that
had been accumulated over the years and
also over Saudi Arabia's massive defense
budgets.
So today the power of the prince is
practically total.
Hey,
well this isn't something normally that
never has such a young man had so much
power before.
I've until now,
the norm was for the country to be
controlled by seniors have 80 or more
years.
We were very reluctant to go for any
kind of change,
but all of a sudden changes in the foot
because what Mohammed bin Salman is
trying to do with Saudi Arabia is turn
it into a new United Arab Emirates,
a country which the prince has an
enormous amount of admiration for later.
We're going to see just how he is doing
this,
but for now you need to bear something
in mind.
The youth of the country chair been
Salmaan as the savior of the kingdom and
this is a country where half of its
population is less than 25 years olds.
And so in a country like that,
it's pretty important.
But so now you might be wondering,
why does this man come from?
How can such a young man who have so
much power?
Well,
he's the son of the current king.
Wait just a second before you explained.
Well of course he is because you need to
know that being the son of the king in
the Saudi Arabia wasn't always such an
important thing.
In fact,
Banal Been Somal is not even the ad to
the Saudi throne battle over the throne.
It's all one bin.
Abdulaziz is the king of Saudi Arabia.
He is the son of the man who was
considered the founder of the country.
Abdulaziz been sold since cell died in
1953 the kingdom has been inherited by
brother,
BAFTA,
brother Doula.
Z's been sowed,
had 17 known wives and it is calculated
that he also had around 32 sons,
so there were quite a few potential
heirs.
The thing is that when the current is
king,
he was believed to be the 25th son
reached power a few years ago in 2015
the first thing he did was change the
laws of succession even though some of
his brothers are still alive,
he has decided to put to the new
generations in charge of this process to
do this.
He has decided to appoint his nephew,
Muhammad bin Nayef,
who is closer to Washington than others
and he has been in charge of security
for the last few years as well as the
secret services and the fight against
fundamentalism.
However,
it seems like young,
the Hamad bin Selma on the main
character in this video it seems he's
not very happy about that and it seems
that he is taking aim at the throne.
He wants to be the future king of Saudi
Arabia,
so here's eagerness for reforms could be
explained as an attempt to to gain
popularity.
In fact that is what most analysts
currently think that as well.
It does make sense.
The fall of the price of oil has given
Mohammed bin Selma and the opportunity
to aim for the throne,
which is something his father obviously
supports.
If Saudi vision 2030 starts showing good
result in,
someone will be in a better position to
ask for a reward and it's become
potentially the new add to the throne.
However,
there are a few problems on the road
ahead both for been some on as well as
the country.
On the one hand,
there are problems inside the royal
family.
Then someone has made a lot of enemies
who accused him of being power hungry.
On the other hand,
his father,
the currents king is quite old,
81 years.
He seems to have some memory issues.
So this means that there are two
possible scenarios ahead.
If the current's king,
there was so many more years,
the Prince bin on,
we'll be able to consolidate his power.
However,
if the king doesn't live so long,
the current had been some Alan's cousin
could become the new king and wish
goodbye.
Both do the prints and his Saudi vision
it
Mars.
The reality is is that this is how
Monica is work,
but I'm pretty sure that some of you by
now you're probably thinking,
well this is all fascinating Simon,
but why should I care what happens into
Saudi Arabia?
Well,
you should.
Katherine's probably more than you
think.
Saudi Arabia is still the biggest oil
producer now and it is also the most
important and influential country in the
Arab.
Well,
evolution towards openness for this
country.
It could be something very positive for
the world's cans for now,
the plan,
Saudi vision 2030 it seems to be the
only opportunity for the country to
progress and evolve.
But now that we've said that,
what exactly is the plan for this
coming?
Sure.
Incorrigibles
so far in today's story,
we've seen a handsome prince and the
battle over the throne,
but we need a third ingredients for this
Saudi soap opera,
and that's luxury hands money.
Well,
of all the royal families in the world,
the Saudis,
the royal household of Saudi Arabia
mights be the most addicted to money and
luxury as well.
Now you're going to see why,
as we have mentioned in several videos,
the fall of oil prices is jeopardized,
many countries and among them is Saudi
Arabia only in 2016 and even though many
adjustments were made,
the country had a deficit of more than
$80 billion and is now the question
becomes what can they do in order to fix
such a hole in their budget?
Well,
in 2016 the Saudi government announced
that the country was going to go on a
diet.
For the first time in decades,
austerity reached Saudi Arabia.
The government have been Salmaan started
with reductions in public wages,
cancelled many projects,
whose profitability was uncertain,
reduce subsidies and gasoline,
water,
electricity.
This,
it was a pretty huge shock for one of
the most subsidized economies in the
wells.
I mean,
up until now,
do you have,
you will oil.
It helps pay for everything in Saudi
Arabia.
However,
hold on for just a moment because,
well,
that's not the whole story.
Under Solomon's rule,
prince is still enjoy many material
privileges.
The subsidization system hasn't changed
for the royal household.
Take a look at this.
The King of Saudi Arabia has ultra
luxurious palaces all over the world
that are available to him in Marbella in
Spain.
He has l Roseo a palace inspired by no
less than the White House.
But I mean,
it's gotta be pretty boring,
right?
I have to go to the same palace all the
time.
I mean,
how tiresome so lost some of the king
built a new and gigantic palace in
Tangier.
In Morocco.
The palace has its very own hospital in
here.
The king gets French seafood delivered
direct from France.
But I mean,
Hey,
what's the problem with chartering a few
airplanes so the king can eat some nice
and lobsters?
Right?
Oh.
And by the way,
when the king of Saudi Arabia travels,
he travels and big and his last tour
around Asia in 2016 the king traveled
with 1500 people and he took with him to
Mercedes Benz s 600 limousines.
In order to carry it all 27 planes had
to be used.
Yes.
So it seems that this is what the royal
family,
you can sit as austerity and the print
is our main character.
He's no different either.
During holidays in France and at the
same time,
oil prices were falling.
Print.
Salmaan saw the yacht of the Russian
magnate,
Uri Sheffler.
It was love at first sight.
He sent an assistant right away in order
to close the deal.
Solman bought it for 550 million US
dollars.
Sorry.
Now you know how the family likes to
live animals?
Well,
they are quite a big family.
It's all estimations indicate that the
Saudi royal family has around 15,000
members.
The government has evaded the question
of membership numbers,
but even low and estimates,
but it did about 5,000 people.
As we're talking about people who live
thanks to the public budget and to have
all kinds of privileges.
They are paid impressive salaries.
They have access to hospitals which are
essentially five star palaces ans they
do profitable business with the
government.
They have incredibly luxurious spends,
honestly rather incredible lifestyles,
and the reality is that that is very,
very expensive according to estimations
from the u s government.
Since transparency is not a tradition in
the royal family of,
they spend about $2 billion every year
in order to keep up their sumptuous
lifestyle.
Other estimates indicate the royal
family takes over a million barrels of
oil a day,
which is 10% of the national production
progress of Saudi vision 2030
this wanting to all of this,
the transition of Saudi Arabia plans in
vision 2030 keeps moving forward.
Saudi Arabia designs a city of
entertainment almost as big as Las Vegas
bosses.
The truth is that it is moving slowly.
Adams for the time being Saudi Arabia is
regaining better relations with the
United States.
In fact,
that Donald Trump's first international
visitors,
the u s presidents was to react.
But yes,
in order to achieve that to the Saudis
had to sign some pretty big checks.
Trump signs the single largest arms deal
in US history with Saudi Arabia.
We're $350 billion and this has to be
added to the billion dollar contracts
they already have with some of the
largest companies in the United States
and it all has a target in mind.
Saudi Arabia wants to reinforce the
protection it has from the u s to
defendant for impossible enemies such as
Iran.
We're actually going to be discussing
this special relationship in a future
video,
so please do not forget to subscribe,
but leaving the u s aside in the last
few months,
Saudi Arabia has set the world's largest
funder for technological investments.
They have $100 billion available to
invest further more.
The country's eliminating many
restrictions on foreign investments and
some projects are being already
discussed.
Some of these have already been put into
motion such as theme parks,
huge hotel resorts,
and even nuclear power plant
bus plus.
As we have been telling you,
transforming this country won't be easy
at all.
And this is just the start of their very
own soap opera.
This is the huge money wastage of the
royal family,
which means they have to deal with a lot
of criticism from the country's powerful
religious leaders who by the way have a
terrible lack of respect for civil
rights.
Then there is the war in Yemen and the
uncertainty of the air to the Saudi
throne.
So now what do you think about the
luxurious lifestyle of the Saudi royal
family?
Do you think [inaudible] will ever
become some sort of Dubai?
Well,
please leave your answers in the
comments below and do you click like if
you enjoyed this video and don't forget
to subscribe for brand new videos just
like this every Monday and every
Thursday.
And as always I'll see you in the next
video.
And if you want to learn
more about politics and hear even more
of my lovely voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsideredmedia.com
slash podcast yeah.
Okay.